[Musique]
t les trois minutes de vérité tout le
monde en a parlé merci sa belle bête là
ma chérie je sais que tu voulais pas
faire une émission tu reviens demain ce
sera avec nous demain à monsieur
mercredi ce qui lève le mercredi c'est
la journée des enfants hier dans tpm p
on a parlé de maine elle la candidate de
the voice qui a fait polémique après la
découverte de plusieurs messages dans
lesquels elle parlait des attentats en
france on va on va regarder un extrait
de sa prestation dans the voice où elle
chante
alléluia et juste après on va rappeler
ce qui s'est passé et la polémique et la
petite polémique qui a eu autour de huy
zabel et vous vouliez répondre ce soir
c'est parti
[Musique]
3 2
et
il
il a
[Musique]
et
alors là une voix superbe ça on connaît
série c'est l'interprétation et est
fabuleuse et isabelle vous avez donné
votre avis parce que derrière il ya des
tweets qui sont sortis sur cette jeune
fille vous avez donné votre avis et je
vais vous lire quelques tweets qu'on a
enlevé quelques réactions de
téléspectateurs qui voulait avoir des
explications
regardez la réaction d'isabelle sur les
tout propos des attentats de nice elle
avait écrit sur les réseaux c'est bon
c'est devenu une routine un attentat par
semaine et toujours pour rester fidèle
le terroriste point détruit ses papiers
d'identité
c'est vrai que quand on prépare un sale
coup on n'oublie surtout pas de prendre
ses papiers hashtag prenez nous pour des
cons parce que vous trouvez cette
polémique justifié oui concernant menez
dit la vérité
oui moi oui vous vous retrouvez à le
voile non à la chanson en arabe même si
je trouve que par les temps qui courent
ce ça me posez peut-être pas
nécessairement ce qu'elle a postée oui
ça me choque sur les attentats de nice
ça me choque
alors donc eu beaucoup de gens qui ont
réagi bonjour cirilo mena pour vous et
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que veut
dire votre chroniqueuse isabelle
morini-bosc quand elle déclare mon
direct en parlant de mesnel de the void
je ne comprends pas pourquoi elle chante
en arabe surtout par les temps qui
courent choqué par les propos d'isabelle
championnats rares par les temps qui
courent what the fuck chanté en arabe ne
fera jamais de quelqu'un terroristes
encore moins avec une chanson comme
hallelujah le moment où la chroniqueuse
était pmp isabelle morini-bosc dit à
propos de ménage je trouve qu'il ne
fallait pas chanter en arabe par les
temps qui courent des explications cyril
hanouna parce que c'est scandaleux là et
vous savez on vous raconte toujours tout
et on vous dit tout dans l'émission de
isabelle vous avez réagi sur twitter ce
matin moi raciste
allons donc j'ai cru qu'on parlait de
quelqu'un d'autre mais vous avez raison
si j'ai été mal compris c'est que je me
suis fais le je me suis mal fait
comprendre donc repas leur lot sans ce
soir dans des pmp alors il a merci
d'être là déjà besoin d'ailleurs là on
s'est tous exprimé sur ce sujet là moi
je vais effectivement le voile ne me
choquait pas effectivement je vais pas
demander ce qu'elle soit retirée de
l'émission ni rien ça ne me choquait pas
non plus en revanche c'est vrai qu'il
faut aller très très vite en direct et
moi ce que vous savez que j'aime les
chansons en français dans l'émission
parce que phonétiquement c'est comme ça
qu'on se rend compte si quelqu'un
articule ou pas et je les dis la semaine
dernière je le dit régulièrement sur le
fait qu'elle chante en à ses adhérents
j'ai raison et la rdc que vous ayez dit
et je peux alors je vous le dise abrite
adore je me défendrai toujours vous le
savez mais c'est vrai que même moi vous
voulez vous avez eu marre actions en
direct avec quand vous avez dit voilà
chanter en arabe par les temps qui
courent ça pose aucun brevet on vous
aurait très bien pu dire je pense que
dans ces cas là alors chanté en anglais
chanté en mai oui donc voilà donc qui
est ça qui est vraiment accepter des
gens et je peux comprendre
tafer serait un chinois en serbo-croate
et tous arrêtés rigoureusement la même
chose ça a été en deux temps d'abord il
fallait très vite en direct dans un
temps tripale j'adore cette chanson
j'aime pas qu'on la touche j'aime quand
la chambre telle qu'elle était ça
c'était le premier temps et le deuxième
temps effectivement il ya le contexte de
cette jeune femme et donc du coup il ya
tout un ensemble qui moi m'a semblé
ambiguë mais ça ne va pas ou de là je
vois pas l aurait été le cerveau coiteux
leurs effets des tweets en serbo-croate
et elle aurait chanté à sa me crois que
j'aurais dit pas il ya une ambiguïté
alors il ya les chameaux croate qui
s'appelle un tarif du chinois auraient
été n'importe quoi élan quelqu'un a dit
la semaine dernière regardait comme les
racines déjà la semaine dernière serait
douar édouard richard du nino ferrer à
la 10 éme bien qu'ils chantent en
français et ben oui parce que quand un
chanteur chante en français dans ce vol
sans voix phonétiquement celle articule
s'il chante bien et c'est facile de
faire du yaourt en anglais ça je le dis
depuis lors de l'émission donc donc les
halles isabelle pourquoi pas louer
racisme là dedans
non oui non mais c'est sûr que non mais
voilà votre votre frappe et elle était
voilà oui on peut on peut comprendre
qu'ils auraient loupé elle aurait dû
être développées et c'est vrai que je me
suis arrêté d'abord parce qu'il ya un
temps de parole qui est un parti et puis
parce que parce que parce que voilà je
me suis arrêté comme ça mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec leur assise elle vous vous
réveillez vous êtes vous vous endormez
vous êtes une gentille fille qui
accueille tout le monde chez elle vous
vous réveillez comme moi je vais pas sur
les réseaux sociaux seraient ils
auraient pu se passer six jours avant je
me rende pas heureusement qu'il ya des
gens qui m'ont averti en me disant il ya
un buzz mais un buzz et je voyais même
pas tout en n'étant pas contente de ce
que j'avais dit fière parce que je
laisse comme un terminal est ce que vous
avez à dire aux téléspectateurs
on réagira nous tous dessus demain sur
la réponse d'isabelle si elle vous a
convaincu ou pas mais juste parce qu'on
doit finir l'émission il avait qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire aux téléspectateurs
qui ont été choqués ce soir et qu'est ce
que vous avez à leur répondre
eh ben c'est bien qu'ils aient demandé
des explications alors ceux qui ont
condamné par principe de façon
extrêmement violente sans hélas on peut
pas empêcher ça il y en a même que j'ai
pas vu il ya aussi des gens qui
défendent pas présenté et que je n'ai
pas vu mais ceux qui ont été choqués et
qu'on demandait des explications
je les en remercie parce que moi je suis
quelqu'un de nuancer si on me demande
une explication je la donne et si on me
dit il faut que tu t'expliques plus j'en
suis tout à fait là
c'est mon boulot c'était des gens très
choqué mais je comprends que des gens
qui ont été choqués je pense que des
gens qui est réellement ont fait c'est
une époque qui domine et qui exclut la
nuance donc quand vous êtes nuancé c'est
une école une époque extrêmement
compliqué surtout quand vous êtes en
direct qu'on est neuf et que vous dites
bon ben savage en reste là j'aurais pas
dû en rester là
j'ai poursuivre est-ce que je vous
promets jusqu'en isabelle depuis des
années et je peux vous dire qu'il n'ya
pas plus ouverte qu'isabelle isabelle
c'est juste voilà cc c'est quelqu'un qui
qui vaut même nous parfois on comprend
pas ce qui sort de sa bouche un peu mais
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai et on
aime comme ça et je vous dit isabelle
elle n'est raciste en aucun cas si
vraiment il a bel v avait a été sérieuse
dans ses propos ou tenez des propos
sérieux tout le temps est mesurée dans
l'émission je pense qu'elle ne serait
pas dans sa reddition
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on aime et isa je
te le dis moi je sais comment tu es
passé et je veux dire je sais que c'est
une maladresse de tabac mais qui était
assise sur les racistes ou voilà c'est
juste une maladresse donc on vous
demande des crises et isabelle et
isabelle tu sais que je t'aime et je
sais ce que tu vaux je sais ce que tu
dis et je sais que tu es la plus ouvert
[Applaudissements]